there is
like how
i just like i am i am tongue-tied that
we live in an environment where somebody
can go from
i'm a 60 000 a year yoga instructor
went nowhere model doesn't have anything
to show for it
runs into a guy her life improves
exponentially the
lives of her kids improve exponentially
for a good 15 years but because he
maintained that for 15 years the courts
now basically
say to her and him well you did that for
15 years so you
can't take away what you were giving her
you can take away
whatever you want but you can't take
away the money see
i've said this before hypergamy is
hardwired
into family law it's designed for women
to optimize
themselves on a financial basis and it
doesn't encourage them to behave well
you'd think that you know a reasonable
person would just say
okay our relationship ran its course we
had a disagreement or
a number of disagreements you know we
couldn't see eye to eye on things
um you go your way and i'll go my way i
had a you know i had a good time
uh he'd probably say just keep the
mercedes and keep the fur coats and the
ring and
whatever you know we'll call it a day
but that's not enough
he has to maintain her lifestyle for at
least
another 10 years the original ruling by
the first judge was indefinitely
i mean he would have had to pay until
either one of them died probably right
but when it was appealed it was reduced
down to 10 years
i'm sure he's not going to you know like
it's not like he's gonna have to sell or
liquidate his entire
estate to pay for this but it's a big
chunk of money
that is being extorted from this guy and
like he's being treated like tax cattle
is basically what it is
just just let him get milked
and send it on over to lisa and let her
enjoy it
whatever yeah it's it's just you know
look there's a good point here he's made
every mistake you could make that's
that's a very good point any
any guy out there can make this
identical mistake if they don't walk
into this
uh with their eyes wide open funny part
she'll be broke 10 years later i
wouldn't doubt it
i mean you know she's she's probably
um i mean there's probably something
written into the ruling that says that
if she remarries
uh or if she uh cohabitates with a guy
then she's gonna lose access to the
support payments so my guess is she's
probably
because she's she's not a dummy
obviously she's probably going to find a
replacement for michael
i don't know that she's going to get
anywhere near the top 93 richest people
in canada to replace him but
i'm sure that the money will last a good
long time for i mean six and a half
million dollars is a lot of money you
can basically retire on that never have
to worry again
you